foreign
[Music]
There She Goes Again British prime
minister Theresa May recently spoke at
the United Jewish Israel appeal dinner
and once again she likened me to Jihad
terrorists
in the midst of a long boast about how
much she opposes anti-Semitism May said
and I acted to keep those who peddle
hatred and extremism out of our country
I kicked out Abu Hamza in Abu Katara I
stopped Pamela Geller Robert Spencer and
Pastor Terry Jones because islamophobia
comes from the same Wellspring of hatred
and I stopped people like duodome coming
to Britain because nothing excuses
anti-Semitism not comedy not satire not
even irony anti-Semitism is just hatred
and it is just wrong
so as far as Theresa May is concerned
Pamela Geller and I are the islamophobic
equivalents of Abu Hamza and Abu Katara
may expect her audience to be familiar
with Abu Hamza and Abu Katara and for
good reason since both are notorious in
Britain although neither lives there now
Abu Hamza is in solitary confinement in
a supermax U.S prison for among other
things conspiring to set up a training
camp for Jihad terrorists in Bly Oregon
Abu katata was convicted of plotting the
Jihad Massacre of Americans and Israelis
in Jordan to which he has now returned
now have I plotted to fly a jetliner
into Big Ben or blow myself up in a
crowd of britons no of course I've never
plotted called for or approved of any
kind of terrorist or vigilante violence
against anyone and thus Theresa May
speaking of me is the flip side of Abu
Hamza and Abu Katara is beyond
outrageous it's so ridiculous that it
should lead any competent member of the
British Parliament to question not only
Teresa May's Fitness to remain in office
but her sanity
could Theresa May herself really believe
this nonsense does she actually believe
that standing against Jihad terror is
essentially equivalent to plotting Jihad
Terror
islamophobia she says of which I'm
supposedly guilty and thus barred from
the UK comes from the same Wellspring of
hatred as anti-Semitism and so she is
boasting to a Jewish group about banning
me a wholehearted supporter of Israel
and Pamela Geller a Jewish woman from
Britain and then she's claiming that
she's against anti-Semitism pull my
other leg Theresa May's implication is
that anti-muslim rhetoric that is public
discussion of the Jihad threat and what
can be done about it leads inexorably to
the demonization of Muslims and
ultimately to genocide this is
ridiculous overheated rhetoric that only
hinders the prospects of any genuine
discussion of the Salient issues and
that is probably the goal all along the
purpose of May's equivalence of
islamophobia with anti-Semitism is
designed to intimidate people into
thinking the criticism of Islamic Jihad
Terror and Sharia oppression of women
gays and others leads to the
concentration camps unless there must be
no criticism of these things
the unstated assumption is that if one
group was unjustly accused of plotting
subversion and violence and was
viciously persecuted and massacred on
the basis of those false accusations
than any group accused of plotting
subversion and violence must be innocent
and any such accusation must be in
service of preparing for their
subversion and Massacre
this is simply a method to foreclose on
any criticism of jihad Terror and Sharia
oppression by equating me with Jihad
terrorists Theresa May is essentially
saying that opposing Jihad terror is as
bad as working for Jihad Terror and that
is exactly how may is acting now in her
shabby little police state British
authorities are hounding and persecuting
foes of jihad while Jihad preachers roam
free and act with impunity how will
Britain look in five years or ten as
this continues future generations of
free britons if there are any will curse
the name of Theresa May as one of the
chief betrayers of their Nation
I'm Robert Spencer a Shulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]